the media pushed president biden as the
most normal normal person who has ever
normaled but there is only one problem
his policy not normal i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand-up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
well you may have noticed the government
preparing to spend more money than has
ever been created by man or god it's
pretty impressive stuff
that means that you probably should be
looking to diversify your investments
at this point we are now at the mercy of
one party control an agenda driven by
tax and spend
economics forget about the social
ramifications fiscally you can expect
compounded growth of the national debt
the systematic evaluation
of the united states dollar so is there
there really is only one question
what are you doing to protect your
savings well what you should be doing is
at least diversifying a little bit
into precious metals birch gold group
can help you with that birch gold group
will help you diversify a portion of
your savings in ira are eligible 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
they are the premier precious metals ira
company in america with an eight plus
better business bureau rating
countless five star reviews thousands of
satisfied customers there's a tidal wave
of inflation coming
gold is your hedge text ben to 47 47 47
for your free information kit on
precious metals ira
or to speak with a birch gold
representative today you can't afford to
be
left standing holding the bag as the
government proceeds to
make your savings worth very very little
instead you should at least diversify
right that's the smart thing to do every
financial advisor will tell you to
diversify
one great way to diversify precious
metals time is running out you can
protect your savings right now text ben
47 47 talk to my friends at birch gold
group again text ben
247 47 47 okay so
years ago there was a trend in fashion
it was called norm coring
okay norm coring is a term that is a
mashup of two terms
normal and hardcore right you were
hardcore normal
was the basic idea of this the the term
was coined
in 2013 there was a trend casting group
called cahole and they published
a report in which they talked about norm
coring the idea was to blend into the
crowd you were going to start wearing
like
j crew clothes and stuff from the gap
right this was norm core you're going to
be militantly normal
okay so this is the media's attempt
to to do biden is the normal core guy
that's what they're going to do so biden
campaigned
in 2020 as i'm going to return to
normalcy right this
is so crazy everything is nuts and of
course this was the call from the moment
that trump entered office was
we cannot we can never pretend this is
normal this is not normal every single
thing trump did was
this is absolutely not normal even if it
was totally normal and if he fired a u.s
attorney
which had every power to do and happened
pretty regularly when an administration
enters offices
this is not normal we cannot pretend
this is normal now
there are a lot of things about
president trump weren't normal right i
mean president trump like to tweet a lot
president trump likes a crazy stuff on a
fairly regular basis
president trump was certainly the only
person as the president of the united
states who have uttered the word kofi
right president trump a lot about him
that wasn't normal but
here was the weird thing for a lot of
conservatives about president trump
well he himself was not a normal human
and while he himself was this
garrulous and and bloviating real estate
reality tv star i mean that's what he
was
many of his policies super normal right
restoring america on the military stage
perfectly normal lowering taxes
perfectly normal putting in place judges
who are going to properly interpret the
law
perfectly normal right his actual policy
was super normal compared to the
absolute abnormality of the obama
administration which radically
moved us in the direction of identity
politics which revised the relationship
entirely between the united states
government and the american citizen
which completely racialized american
politics if you compare
not the personal manner and affect of
the commander-in-chief
right if you compare the personal affect
of the commanders and chiefs barack
obama was more normal than than trump
and biden is more normal than trump if
you compare the policy trump was more
normal than both
like a lot more normal than both because
if you look at the shift of radical
change radical change was coming from
obama it was not coming from trump
there was no radical change in policy
there's a bit of a of a backtrack
on some of the radical change of obama's
policy but even there it wasn't as
radical as you would hope if you were a
conservative right we were still trying
is spending four trillion
dollars a year we were still blowing up
the amount of money that the government
was spending
so his policy was a lot more normal
trump's was than obama's now biden comes
in
and what we're going to do is we're
going to say okay we're restoring
normalcy this was biden's entire
campaign
he's the most normal normal who is ever
normal what a normie he's just a normal
dude who normals
for a living like that's that's all he's
been for 50 years
he has been normal i mean sure he's not
super normal sure i mean he's been in
government service since he was 29 years
old he was elected to the senate at the
age of 29.
sure he's spent virtually every moment
since then
either on the public dole or making
money having been on the public dole
sure he doesn't actually live a normal
lifestyle for most americans
right i mean it happens to be true that
by any american standard at this point
in his life he's a very very wealthy man
i think his net worth is somewhere in
the neighborhood of about 10 million
dollars
but he's the most normal person who has
ever normal right i mean he took amtrak
super normal guy and the more normal
they can make biden seem the more you
are going to ignore the fact that his
policy is absolutely
abnormal the more they can make it seem
like joe biden is basically like your
friendly uncle or your friendly grandpa
or your friendly
great-great-great-great-grandpa the more
they can make it seem like that
the lesser you're going to pay attention
to the fact that he's actually cramming
down
a particular view of the united states
that is wrong-headed and a bunch of
policy that is super
not normal and the media are invested in
this because the media are just
the public relations wing of the
democratic party it's astonishing
how fast the media have kicked into gear
on this one on virtually every front
they just uh we on the right we said you
know what your newfound aggressiveness
against the trump administration
we find it weird because you didn't do
any of that when obama was president
they're like no we're aggressive with
everybody and then biden enters
office and they just start slavering i
mean it's the best little whorehouse in
texas for the biden administration over
there
it's incredible okay so let me give you
an example
so yesterday jen sackey the white house
press secretary very normal everybody
there is normal no
no normal okay so jen zaki she is taking
questions on her cell phone
for the president of the united states
and she tweets out last week i asked you
for your questions and you delivered
answered a bunch here i'm looking
forward to doing this again soon spoiler
revealing potus's favorite ice cream
and president biden tweeted back can
confirm it's chocolate chip
so normal man so normal i mean he's so
normal that his favorite ice cream is
chocolate chip
which is like the most normal ice cream
right i mean if you said vanilla then
you'd be like oh well
he doesn't like chocolate and he said
chocolate but probably he doesn't like
vanilla
so and if you said cookie dough you'd be
like well you know that that a lot of
carbs in there so instead he was just
like
chocolate chip and it was wow look how
normal that guy is that guy is so normal
i've never met somebody as normal as joe
biden so joshua who's writing i
typically like at the atlantic he
immediately tweets out
it's so nice to have a boring president
okay and that's gonna be the theme he's
a boring president now
you can have a boring man who is
president without him being a boring
president
this is the thing you can have a boring
man who is the president of the united
states
without the presidency being
particularly boring okay woodrow wilson
extraordinarily boring human being or
like just a boar from top to bottom
his presidency was one of the worst
presidencies in american history it was
characterized by vast amounts of
terribleness
you have perfectly normal people as
president of the united states and yet
the presidency is not boring because it
turns out
the presidency is not just the
personality the presidency is what you
do with the power the presidency is the
policy that you implement that affects
at this point 330 million americans
yash monk then followed up he said folks
i have no doubt that like any president
joe biden will get plenty of things
wrong i'll speak up when he does but if
you don't feel deep relief that we now
have a decent incompetent man in the
white house we have very different
assessments of the past four years
okay well what if i'm mostly concerned
as i was during the trump administration
with the policy that comes out of the
white house that affects me
what if i'm mostly concerned with the
direction the united states moves now
none of that is an attempt to justify
the various excesses and insanities of
the trump white house
but i think that we can acknowledge on a
baseline level that the policy pursued
by the trump administration was
shockingly normal
again for a president who was definitely
not a normal dude
that was a shockingly normal policy
white house and then
we get this which is he's so normal guys
we can he's so normal we can go to sleep
we just go to sleep we don't even have
to do our jobs here in the media
in fact it's over we no longer have to
worry about anything
okay so the norm coring the the attempt
to pretend that joe biden is like the
most normal person who has ever lived
is so in swing on the left i mean to the
point
where they are now out there taking the
least normal parts of biden and making
them normal
it's pretty incredible so here's brian
stelter who
reliable sources he's supposed to be the
media watchdog and instead of course he
is just joe biden's lap dog
here he was honestly i'm just my new
nickname for the main for the
establishment media when it comes to
democratic administrations they're the
human centipede they're just the human
centipede anyway
here's here's brian stelter explaining
that joe biden is making
news boring again he's making news more
see here's the thing
if you were a news person brian stelter
the news would not be boring
he's pursuing some fairly radical policy
right off the bat we'll get to that in a
moment
but it's boring because you see all you
wanted to cover trump made their job so
easy
he really did the reason that trump made
their job easy is because every day they
would get up
they would look at trump's twitter feed
and that would decide what they covered
that day
he would literally just tweet out the
news cycle he'd be like
this country is a bipolar i mean oh my
god that's 12 hours of content get me a
panel
jamel hill i i want get i you know i
need on air right now get michael eric
dyson on the phone stat the president
tweeted out that a country is a bleep
hole country
and everybody's like that okay yeah
that's like not right but i'm just
wondering what that has to do with
policy
i'm like no no no no no no not normal
we're gonna have 12 hours of not normal
with chi
runs not normal right that was the whole
the entire trump administration was that
the truth is the saddest people in the
world in the media that trump's twitter
got banned
are the members of the media because now
they actually are supposed to have to do
their jobs but here's the thing they're
not going to do their jobs
instead they have literally their new
policy in the media
is to declare themselves irrelevant i've
never seen
anything like this in the media we felt
that we were relevant during the trump
administration
because we were calling balls and
strikes i'm a conservative i was going
to give you my opinion
of what trump did i was going to give
you my opinion of yes the tweets but
also the policy
the media were like no we're not going
to cover the policy at all we're just
going to cover the tweets
and then everything with regard to
policy will be seen through the prism of
the tweets
but now that a democrat is in the white
house and the democrats have congress
now the media are declaring that they no
longer are relevant
i've never heard of anything like this
it's amazing
they have the same perspective about
their job that i would if i were a
politician which is my job would be to
make myself irrelevant so you can live
your life but the media their job is not
to be irrelevant their job
is to cover the news but here's brian
stelter of reliable sources explaining
basically we're done the news is boring
you don't have to watch anymore
turn off cnn what is going on here
here's brian stelter
is president biden making the news
boring again
people are always asking what the media
will do post post-president trump
this week after biden's inauguration
they've been asking are reporters going
through withdrawal
are they missing trump's tweets are they
lost without
outrages to cover these headlines from
from axios and other websites
point out that the biden's plan is dull
by design
so is he making the news boring again
is he is he making the news boring so
and then he shows a couple of headlines
right axios biden's dull by design plan
the atlantic boring
is better mashable joe biden's first
presidential tweet is refreshingly
boring see he's so normal guys
normal boring with normalcy and
boringness
isn't that amazing by the way stelter
then tweeted out a chiron
on his show this is the chiron saki
promises to share
accurate info in parentheses how
refreshing
what do you think your job is brian
stelter like seriously
what do you perceive your job to be how
refreshing
okay so here's the thing every single
person who gets up at the white house
podium says they're about to provide you
accurate information they then lie to
you
okay this has happened for every single
white house press secretary of whom i'm
aware
some of them lied less than others dana
perrino and ari fleischer lied less than
robert gibbs and jay carney
but the the basic idea that you in the
media be like how refreshing a
politician has promised me honesty
literally the opposite of your job your
job is to say yes i know you're
promising me honesty
and now i'm going to hold you
accountable but they don't do that they
have no intention
of doing that i mean the wild shift
between look how normal
and boring this is and five minutes ago
it was everything is a crisis every
single thing is a crisis
it's absolutely astonishing right here's
a flashback right here
so brian seltzer was saying this is
we're back to normal guys it's boring
it's normal
this is brian stelter just a few months
ago being like nothing is normal
there's not a single thing that's
happening that's normal right now
it's like new orleans floods every day
it's like the plains go into the towers
every day
and to look away or act like it's now
normal
or acceptable is a disgrace to the
victims
okay i just gonna point out while you
guys are talking about joe biden's ice
cream flavor
well you guys are talking about how
normal joe biden is and the new boring
and the new normal
more people are dying on a daily basis
in the united states than have ever died
from covet in the entire history of
covet
just gonna point that out so if we were
if we were the media and we were to
cover this consistently right now
brian stelter would have been on tv
yesterday he'd been like look there was
joe biden tweeting out about chocolate
chip ice cream
yesterday was 9 11 in the united states
yesterday planes were flying into
buildings in the united states and this
guy was
tweeting about chocolate chip ice cream
how did
this is not normal but no no they're
never going to do that right cause it's
so normal everything's normal
and the media are determined to talk
about how normal this is
okay so last week one of the reporters
in the white house
press room asked jen saki does joe miss
being a candidate these are the kind of
questions that you are going to get from
your
establishment media the human centipede
over here
presidents and candidates have some
events where
they're fun for the candidate the the
big crowd
and the acceptance speech of the
convention the big crowd
at the inauguration big rallies
because of kobet this president has
been denied all those has he ever been
at all wistful about sort of missing the
fun
parts of being a candidate and
the inauguration look at how jen
sackey's face
reacts to that question so jen sackey's
face is like it's like when my
it's like when one of my kids asks a
cute question to my wife that is
that is what that looks like she's
looking at this reporter like he's her
child
asking a dumb but sweet question because
that is a dumb but sweet
does he ever does he ever feel like he
missed out on having big crowds joe
biden does he ever feel like
he missed it in the first
48 hours of his presidency he signed
into law 13 executive orders
many of them extremely radical and your
question is did he miss out on having
crowds
you guys i wonder why no one trusts you
seriously no one trusts you
and meanwhile the media are just they're
openly declaring themselves
irrelevant it's unbelievable again i
keep coming back to this because it's
astonishing to me i
i i almost can't fathom doing this
it's the opposite of what everyone else
in life does which is
you make it relevant to everybody else
what your job
is right but the media whose literal job
is to cover the news like well i guess
there's no more news to cover i guess we
just don't we won't cover it anymore
so glenn kessler who is the fact checker
at the washington post he's like you
know we're not going to need to fact
check them like trump you're we're
running top we had a running list
of the number of times trump lied we're
not going to have to deal with your
biden because he's a truth teller guys
he's a truth teller here is the editor
and chief writer for the washington post
fact checker
glenn kessler announcing we don't need
to fact check them the way that we did
donald trump no no they would no no
i assume the biden you know i did five
years of obama
uh and uh i assume the biden uh
presidency will be a lot like the obama
presidency and that they will be
responsive
uh and will be able to quickly back up
what they're saying
and occasionally the president will go
off kilter particularly when he's
you know speaking extemporaneously and
not following something that
previous descriptive previously been
factual in the very
first press conference jen sackey and
biden by the way
lied repeatedly lied repeatedly about
the idea that there was no vaccine plan
lied repeatedly about it that's a big
lie that's not a small lie that is a
very very large lie
is the idea they were handed nothing the
day of the inauguration
over one million vaccinations were
performed in the united states they were
not handed nothing
okay if trump had come in he'd be like
there was no plan at all none none zero
zero plan i have to ramp this up from
zero everyone's like that's a lie that's
not true
how dare he and now they're you know
what it'll just be like the obama
yes it will be like the obama
administration that obama repeatedly
lied people in his administration
bragged about lying to you guys
and you guys insisted they were honest
to you like an abused girlfriend
the media i know yeah i know my
boyfriend cheats on me regularly and uh
he meets up with like random strangers
and does blow in the bathroom but
he's really a good guy he would never
lie to me he never like sure
i checked his cell phone and it was just
full of pictures with him and instagram
models but he would never cheat on me
that stop that why are you saying that
about him stop it
this is your media amazing my favorite
is that they continue to bring jake
harney on tv to talk about
the integrity of the biden
administration talk about somebody who
has a bit of a rooting interest
jay carney was the press secretary for
barack obama he worked with jen sackey
and harry is like you know who's you
know he's got a lot of integrity i mean
i'm going to shock you with this you
know he's got a lot of integrity the
people i agree with here's jay carney
the administration telegraphed very
early uh this is
how they were going to be honest and
truthful instead of spinning about it's
you know
today joe biden as president tomorrow
covets you know the beginning of the end
is near
they've been very clear that it's going
to get worse before it gets better and i
think
you begin to make deposits in the
integrity bank
when you when you're honest with the
press and therefore the people and i and
i was glad to see that and i know we're
going to see more of it by the way
they've been so clear about how it's
gonna get worse before it get better
that joe biden said that he was gonna
shut down the virus that was like part
of his actual pitch
just gonna note that okay i mean like
this october 30th 2020 quote i'm not
going to shut down the country
i'm not going to shut down the economy
i'm going to shut down the virus joe
biden's official twitter account
okay but so much honesty guys happening
so much okay but it's not just about the
honesty
and the integrity and the normalcy of a
biden administration
it's also about how normal biden is on a
personal level the guy is just normal
beyond normal
so my favorite piece of the weekend i
really love this piece because
i'm a watch guy right i like luxury
watches i don't just wear the vincero i
have like a bunch of luxury watches
at home so i know something about
watches and there's a piece in the new
york times
about joe biden and his watches and now
joe biden owns a number of very
expensive watches
by very expensive i mean these are
watches that price upwards of six
thousand dollars seven thousand dollars
eight thousand dollars
so there's an article in the new york
times their task in this article should
they choose to accept it
is to turn it into a normal habit to
collect watches now i'm fully aware
that it is not a normal habit to have
many expensive watches i know this
because like five years ago i didn't
have any expensive watches
and it was it was a luxury that as i've
been able as i was able to afford it i
was able to indulge in that luxury but
it is not a
normal thing it's not a normal thing
when i give watches
to friends and family which i do fairly
regularly when i do that
it's like a big deal to them as it
should be because these are expensive
watches
so the new york times has to somehow
come up with the idea that joe biden is
the super normalest guy who ever
normalled
well he has super expensive watches so
here's how they do it listen to this i
love this so much
the article is titled joe biden watch
geek in chief
recent presidents not named trump have
tended to wear every man timepieces such
as timex and chinola
here's what the piece says president
biden may cast his arrival in the white
house as a return to business as usual
at 1600 pennsylvania avenue but there's
at least one way he's breaking from
prevailing presidential tradition
he wears a rolex at his inauguration mr
biden laid his hand on the family bible
wearing a stainless steel rolex datejust
watch with a blue dial
a model that retails for more than seven
thousand dollars and is a far cry from
the every man time pieces that every
president not named trump has warned
conspicuously in recent decades okay so
here is here's cheat number one how much
does the watch cost
so it's a rolex datejust right that's a
nice watch that's a very nice watch
how much does that cost so they say that
it retails for more than seven thousand
dollars
how much more they click through to the
link if you click through the link the
answer is it retails not for
about seven thousand dollars it retails
for seventy nine hundred bucks almost
eight thousand dollars so instead of
them wording it as the watch is worth
almost eight thousand dollars
they word it that the watch is worth
over seven thousand dollars hmm
interesting how they do that okay then
they say to many a president wearing a
luxury watch might not seem unusual
shouldn't the leader of the free world
wear a power watch befitting his
position
never mind that it cost the equivalent
equivalent of a dozen or so stimulus
checks
that concept was a was widely accepted
once back when dwight d eisenhower and
lyndon johnson
posed guiltlessly for oval office
portraits wearing gold rolexes not for
nothing is rolex's storied gold day-date
model known
as the president such political power
watches however had gone out of style in
the internet age when most recent
presidents and politicians in general
seem to consider the luxury watch as a
signifier of out of touch elitism
kevin gets you more of this in just one
second because it is just spectacular
the way that the new york times twist
joe biden owns expensive watches into
but look how normal he is while owning
expensive watches is it's amazing it's
really great
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that you
don't have a bunch of money to spare
instead what you need to do
is not spend time at the post office and
save money on all of the postal
uh all of the packages that you are
sending on a day-to-day basis this is
why you need to head on over to
stamps.com stamps.com allows you to mail
and ship anytime anywhere
right from your computer you can send
letters ship packages pay a lot less
with discounted rates from usps ups and
more
here at dailywear we have been using
stamps.com since 2017 we don't waste our
time and we don't waste our money
stamps.com brings the services of the us
postal service and ups right to your
computer
stamps.com is a must-have for any
business with stamps.com you get
discounts of up to 40 percent
off post office rates and up to 62 off
ups shipping rates not to mention
stamps.com is a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters
stamps.com it's a no-brainer it saves
you time it saves you money it's no
wonder nearly 1 million small businesses
already use stamps.com so stop wasting
your time going to the post office and
go to stamps.com instead there's no risk
with my promo code shapiro you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial
plus free postage and digital scale no
long-term commitments no contracts just
go to stamps.com
click on that microphone at the top of
the homepage type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
promo code shapiro again that is
promo code shapiro okay so back to the
new york times attempting to turn
joe biden's watch habit into a norm core
thing so they say
that bill clinton used to wear a timex
iron man and george w bush
wore a timex indiglio the choice of a
watch that cost 50 bucks or less was
either a man of the people's statement
says the new york times even though mr
bush was an oil scion who went to yale
or a master stroke of old money
preppyism where any hint of gilded
glimmer is considered vulgar
barack obama too avoided heirloom level
timepieces during his presidency he
opted for mid-priced all-american
watches by chinola
or a sporty watch by george gray based
in southern california that cost less
than 500 bucks
this may come as a shock but trump
shattered those norms
he remained on bran during his term
flashing mogul worthy gold what else
watches by patek philippe rolex and
vacheron constantine right those are
very very expensive watches
which brings us to mr biden who seems to
balance both
hierarchical horological sensibilities
horological meaning having to do with
watches he seems to balance both
horological sensibilities
and is unafraid to show off his house
switch swiss watches all stainless steel
including his rolex an omega speedmaster
moonwatch professional
and an omega seamaster diver 300m both
of which retail for around five or six
thousand dollars okay
first of all depends on the model you're
looking at the moonwatch professional
very often retails about eight grand and
the omega c master diver
300m depending if you're getting like
the bond edition that also retails at
about eight grand so what you're talking
about
is at least twenty thousand dollars
worth of watches is what you're talking
about right here
here's the new york times to be fair
none of mr biden's watches scream luxury
at least to watch connoisseurs who are
acclimated to the thin air of swiss
watch prices
wait they don't scream luxury really do
they not
to many people whose entire salary on a
yearly basis
might be fifty or sixty thousand dollars
it seems to me that only twenty thousand
dollars of watches
in excess of that easily might be
considered at least a little bit of
luxury
just a little again there's nothing
wrong with this okay i'm not
anti-collecting luxury watches i collect
luxury watches
i love it i think it's fun okay and i
don't think there's anything wrong with
joe biden doing it i'm just pointing out
that the media
have to take even the things about joe
biden that scream not normal
and then pigeonhole them back into
normal so what they're doing is they're
taking a habit that is not inexpensive
and they're like yeah but that's like a
normal guy would do right i mean like
come on is that come on really
yeah why not his rolex datejust
for example is considered an undisputed
classic but in another sense
almost could be regarded as entry level
for a brand with head turners that
quickly climb
into the five figures so saying the
rolex datejust which is like eight eight
grand
at retail you know yeah that's a really
expensive watch that's like a used car
right there
but and joe biden is captain normalcy
who takes amtrak so it's a little
incongruous
and we didn't want to betray the fact
that joe biden is worth 10 million
dollars owns three separate houses like
we wouldn't want to do any of that
because that seems not normal
but you know here's the thing if you
look at it in a certain way a rolex
datejust is actually just like a timex
like if you compare rolex to other
rolexes it's just like a timex
because the datejust is one of their
down model brands right
it's like if you if you look at the
datejust that's like one of their lesser
expensive watches
okay i could say the exact same thing
it's gonna be very specific about the
patek philippe calatrava
okay calatrava is the baseline of
pathetically patek philippe
is uh in in the hbo show succession
there is a
a great line about patek philippe uh
that the line is is uttered by one of
the uh
sons-in-law of the mogul who's supposed
to be kind of rupert murdoch and he
wants to give his father-in-law a patek
philippe
and when he gives him the watch he says
it's a watch that tells you how rich you
are
right so patek philippe the baseline
calatrava model if you buy it new
is gonna cost you almost twenty thousand
dollars that's a very very upscale
luxury line but compared to other patek
philippe which can run all the way up to
a million dollars that's really down
brand right like a timex
so rolex datejust it's just like a timex
if you compare it to you know like the
rolex daytona
or if you compare it to you know the the
rolex seamaster right if you compare it
to the
to the very the the yacht-master
whatever it is
the seed dweller the james cameron
sea-dweller
okay come on like you're working too
hard here guys likewise his omegas do
not connect fanciness at least in the
eyes of watch snobs the moon watch while
swiss in origin
has been embraced as an american emblem
ever since the apollo 11 astronauts wore
the story model to the moon
uh they do connote fanciness actually
because they cost a lot of money
also they're like the sea master is a
brawny scuba watch worn by daniel
craig's bone breaking james
bond that doesn't connote fanciness
james bond is literally the guy who
wears a tux with the
with the seamaster okay so they are
working
so hard so here's how they finish you
ready
whether a conscious fashion statement or
not the high-end but macho watches
suggest that even at 78
this former high school football star of
the kennedy years still wants to be seen
as a he-man
rugged and young at heart see his
aviator sunglasses they also embody a
classic version of the american dream
that anyone even a kid from scranton can
make it to the pinnacle of power
then again he may just wish to make it
to white house meetings on time
oh so normal guys like he's the american
dream now
if a republican wore an expensive watch
and came from nothing
right if i if the new york times were to
do an article about the fact that i own
expensive watches do you think that it
would be really rooted in
shapiro grew up in a two-bedroom home of
1100 square feet
sharing a room with three siblings with
one bathroom right so six people
1100 square feet one bathroom one phone
right
do you think that it would be about the
rising from humble beginnings to be able
to own an expensive watch or do you
think it would be like
look at that elitist with this expensive
watch
but it's joe biden guys he's so normal
he's so normal
i mean sure he owns a house in
wilmington delaware
that was the property was purchased for
350 bucks and the property's now worth
more than two million dollars sure he
has another one in rehoboth beach
delaware
that's worth like 3 million bucks and
sure they rented a house in mclean
virginia
that is uh over 12 000 square feet but
he's a normal dude
he's not so normal so much normalcy
wow just unbelievable levels of normalcy
okay so this is the goal the goal is
we are going to push joe biden as a
normal human and the reason we're going
to push joe biden as a normal human is
so we don't have to cover the fact that
his policies absolutely abnormal
and that's the thing the more you
pretend he's normal the less you have to
focus on his policy so for example
he just killed the keystone xl pipeline
that's not a normal thing to do
it just killed at least eleven thousand
american jobs it pissed off our northern
neighbors
in canada ted cruz asked booty judge
about this and booty judge was like
well yeah i understand we're killing
lots of jobs but you have to understand
that overall it's going to create jobs
no it's not
it's not okay it is not a normal policy
to kill keystone xl but we have to
this is a boring presidency guys stop
paying attention to the policy here is
ted cruz
with the the hoping for the incoming
secretary of transportation
booty judge i think the most important
thing is to make sure that
we make good on the promise of the
president's climate vision as being one
that
on net creates far more jobs millions we
hope
i know that won't just happen we'll have
to do a lot of work to make sure that's
real
but getting this right means ensuring
that there are more
good-paying union jobs for all americans
delivered through that infrastructure
vision
right so normal so to just kill 11 000
jobs for no real reason
also normal federal agents were firing
tear gas to defend an ice facility
in portland over the weekend remember
when that was a fascist
remember when trump sent federal agents
to uh to fight back people who are
trying to
invade a federal facility and it was
fascist not normal
not normal this can't happen in america
joe biden does it so normal it's not
even worth reporting on
so normal that when jen sackey was asked
about it at a press conference she
literally did not know that it was even
happening
that's how normal things are okay other
normal things that have been happening
over the weekend so joe biden is now set
to lift restrictions on transgender
military service members
so to understand exactly what this means
you have to understand what the policy
was before
so the actual policy on transgender
service members
was in 2019 rewritten slightly
and the basic idea is that it was okay
to identify as transgender in the
military
there actually was no formal transgender
military ban as implemented
by the united states military but the
the actual
transgender military ban was designed
to prevent essentially people from
joining up
and then suffering from severe mental
illness gender dysphoria and then
needing transgender surgeries that's
what it was designed to do
right so the policy allowed that if you
wanted a transgender surgery the
military could discharge you
because now you're basically joining up
and then you required
surgeries that shouldn't be paid for by
the taxpayer was the basic idea biden is
now reversing that
by the way the idea that this was some
form of discrimination is completely
bizarre considering the fact
that they're a bevy of mental illnesses
that make you ineligible for military
service
according to the balance careers.com
here are some of the disqualifying
medical conditions
for serving in the military no one has a
right to serve in the military
right first of all this is not what i'm
about to say right here none of this is
a referendum an individual transgender
or otherwise
who are joining the military and doing
something far more patriotic than i have
done right
all of those people should be given
enormous enormous tribute this is a
question
of how you make military policy military
policy does not allow the following
people to join the military
if you suffer from adhd you cannot join
the military
unless you can demonstrate passing
academic performance and no use of
medication in the prior year
okay you are not allowed to join
the military if you have a current or
history of academic skills or perceptual
defect
including but not limited to dyslexia if
you have any history of disorders
that have psychotic features like
schizophrenia or paranoid disorder
any mood disorder like depression or
bipolar or psychosis
all of that is disqualifying any history
of mood disorder requiring medication
and or
outpatient care for longer than six
months by a mental health professional
is also disqualifying
also any symptoms of mood and mental
issue that affects social ability school
and learning or work efficiency
disqualifying behavioral disorders
disqualifying
right so they're speech-affected
disorders any speech impedim
any speech impediment stammering
stuttering or other receptive or
expressive language disorder that may
significantly interfere with the ability
to repeat commands
is disqualifying any history of suicidal
behavior
that even includes discussions gestures
or the actual attempt is disqualifying
self-mutilation is disqualifying anxiety
issues
either current or historic panic
agoraphobia social phobia simple phobias
ocd ocd other acute reactions to stress
ptsd all of these are just qualifying
for entry into the service but if you're
a man who believes you're a woman
joe biden believes that should not be
anything that disqualifies you for
service
right that seems fairly radical and kind
of radical
no apparently not apparently that is not
radical
in any way shape or form but
again that's because everything is
normal everything is super duper normal
the policy by the way was until joe
biden came into po into power
that currently serving transgender
troops anyone who signed an enlistment
contract
would be able to continue with plans for
hormone treatments and gender transition
but
no one with gender dysphoria who was
taking hormones or had transitioned to
another gender would be allowed to
enlist
anyone currently serving any currently
serving troops diagnosed with gender
dysphoria will have to serve in birth
gender you can't just switch gender
and barred from taking hormones or
getting transition surgery that was the
trump administration policy
that has been completely overthrown does
that seem like super normal to you
interesting interesting that this is
what is now normal also other things
that are normal they're going to be
pursuing equity above all
by equity the democrats mean that
they're going to be seeking equal
outcome
not the enforcement of equal rights
according to the new york times
in his first days in office president
biden has devoted more attention to
issues of racial equity than any new
president since lyndon baines johnson
a focus that has cheered civil rights
activists and drawn early criticism from
conservatives
in his inauguration speech the president
pledged to defeat white supremacy
using a burst of executive orders on day
one to declare that quote advancing
equity
civil rights racial justice and equal
opportunity is the responsibility
of our whole government he has ordered
his coronavirus response team to ensure
that vaccines are distributed equitably
not on the basis of risk equitably his
1.9 trillion
recovery plan targets underserved
communities by calling for paid leave
for women forced out of jobs
unemployment benefits that largely help
black and brown workers and expanded tax
credits for impoverished americans who
are disproportionately
non-white so they are they are looking
at equity issues
above all right not freedom equity
but don't worry guys this is all normal
this is just this is the new normal
because biden's a normal guy
so don't pay any attention to what his
actual agenda is just pay attention to
the fact that he's a normal dude who
likes chocolate chip ice cream and even
though he wears expensive watches it's
like a normal guy wearing expensive
watches not like a rich guy wearing
expensive watches
okay in a second we're gonna get to more
of the abnormal policy
and what it means for the country we'll
get to that in just one second first let
us talk about the fact that your most
valuable asset is probably your home
right particularly it's your home title
so nobody's going to steal your home
because that's not really a
possibility but your home title can be
stolen and the legal titles to our homes
are kept online where they can be hacked
a cyborg finds your home's title forges
your signature on a quick claim deed
stating you sold your home to him then
takes out a loan against your home until
all the equity is gone
you're not gonna know until the
collection calls pour in you're not
protected by your bank or common
identity theft programmed home title
lock
can protect you in the unlikely event
you become a victim of title theft while
you're a member
home title lock will spend up to a
quarter million dollars in legal fees to
help restore your home's title
so head on over to hometitlelock.com
register your address and see if you are
already a victim then use code radio for
30 free days of protection
that is code radio home title lock dot
com again check them out
at home title lock dot com the last
thing you want to do is leave
your most powerful and most valuable
asset exposed to the gender
the gentle predations of people who
would like to steal your money
go protect your home title today head on
over to hometitlelock.com
use code radio for 30 free days of
protection
alrighty we're going to get back to this
in just one moment we're also going to
get to
impeachment talk and cancel culture
there's a lot going on over the weekend
plus covert
okay like we got to talk about anthony
faucet for a second we'll get to that in
a second first
daily wire we are taking back the
culture we are starting with
entertainment content earlier this month
we released our first film run hide
fight exclusively for daily wire members
you can catch it over at dailywire.com
on our mobile app or
on our streaming apps at apple tv and
roku if you're not a daily wire member
yet
use promo code rhf to get 25 off that is
rhf for 25 off
the early critical reviews for the movie
terribly negative of course
of course because those are the kinds of
movies that we probably will be making
the stuff the critics hate
but that you love audience scores have
exploded
we picked up run hide fight after
hollywood studios turned away from the
quote unquote distasteful subject
because it didn't include
leftist talking points and celebrated
actual bravery run hide fight follows a
17 year old girl who fights back against
school shooters it's terrific it's a
really really good movie our viewers are
loving it
and right now you can catch it over at
dailywire.com on our mobile app or on
our streaming apps at apple tv and roku
if you're not a daily wire member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25 off that is
rhf for 25 percent off you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
so normalcy normally normal so many of
the people who are still pushing at
normalcy are overtly calling for jobiden
to do things that are not normal so for
example david brooks
who is like the normal guy right he is
norm core
he is norm court to the extreme he's the
guy who once praised barack obama
because barack obama creased his khakis
i kid you not that is a thing that david
brooks did so david brooks had a piece
in the new york times over the weekend
in which he said this the biden values
are there humility
vulnerability compassion resilience
interdependence
solidarity donald trump's patriotism was
bloated and fear-based
bidens is the self-confident patriotism
he absorbed by growing up in a certain
sort of country
during the american century biden is
setting the stage
for a moral revival a moral revival
biden has the right agenda the
redistribution of dignity
and then my favorite he just skipped
forward a couple paragraphs
he says i was struck by how republicans
and democrats are committed to each
other across party lines how fervently
they want to break the partisan log jam
is all the normality and then he says
this
if this doesn't work and republicans go
into full obstruction mode democrats
should absolutely kill the filibuster
oh that seems normal oh you mean you're
going to kill the filibuster
which has been the greatest procedural
check
on majoritarian excesses for the past
i don't know 180 years or so that seems
like
kind of not normal actually but no it's
super duper normal
everything is normal over at the
washington post
at e.j dion saying you know what we
don't need unity we need urgency
because that's what normalcy is right
normalcy is ignoring your political
opposition and just running roughshod
over them
so much normalcy amazing normalcy
happening
i i can feel the normalcy breaking out
all over uh just not in the policy
everywhere else the normalcy is breaking
out all over
speaking of normalcy breaking out all
over so anthony fauci now says that he
is going he feels free he's free at last
okay so number one anthony fauci was
made the face of all of this by donald
trump's administration
he also proceeded to botch this thing
six ways from sunday i know we're all
supposed to worship at the altar of
anthony fauci but let me just point out
anthony fouche has not been good okay
anthony fauci
was wrong about people worrying about
this in january
when we were told that donald trump knew
when all anthony fouch he was saying in
late january don't worry about this he
was saying that through february by the
way
he was saying in early march do not mask
up then he was saying
that the rate of hurt immunity was going
to be 70 75 and then later he's like i
was lying it was like 90.
whoops i was just lying about that then
he was in in touch magazine
you know he was taking all the plaudits
what a hero he was just
incredible well now anthony fauci who
literally was on the cover of in touch
magazine while trump was president
he's saying now i feel free he's so free
and here is anthony fauci over the
weekend explaining science will rule in
the biden administration and science
will speak sure
the covert vaccination terms according
to the new york times are going to be
set through equity
not science equity equity is about the
idea
that if you have a disproportionate
number of white old people you should
ignore the elderly in favor of younger
black people right that's what equity
would dictate
because after all we have to have the
same racial outcomes
it's not about protecting the most
vulnerable it's about equity equity here
anyway
here was anthony thaucy the greatest of
all scientists again
in terms of doctors it goes like dr j
doctor strange jonas salk anthony fauci
that's that's how it goes here is dr
fatchi explaining that now he is free
science will rule science will speak men
are ladies babies don't exist until
they're born
go dr fauci the president made it very
clear that
what we were going to do going forward
is everything is going to be based on
science
and evidence and data and science will
rule
and science will speak we will be
transparent
there will be bumps in the road there
will be potholes there might be mistakes
that we make
and what we're going to be doing is
instead of
pointing fingers making blame we're
going to try and fix it
okay so he's uh amazing now the the new
day has gone now let's just be frank
about this
the vaccine that's been put in place was
created under the trump administration
the vaccine plan that will be put in
place
will be a trump administration plan with
very very minor tweaks by the incoming
biden administration
but don't worry guys now we're back to
normal
things are going to be amazing by the
way speaking of things that are normal
apparently joe biden is now going to
reinstate all these covet travel
restrictions
he's imposing a new ban on south africa
only american citizens in south africa
can now come home
everybody else is barred from coming in
i seem to remember when joe biden
thought that doing this with china was a
really really bad idea you know who else
by the way thought it was a bad idea
apparently anthony fauci in the early
days
thought that this was a particularly bad
idea
also it turns out that the incoming
biden administration
literally doesn't have any idea on what
they are doing but the normalcy is there
guys it's really about the normalcy it's
about the normal attitude
it's not so much about what they do as
much as the attitude so xavier becerra
who is a radical leftist okay he was the
attorney general of the state of
california
there's no reason in hell this man
should be up for secretary of health and
human services other than he checks
particularly
particular intersectional boxes like he
has no history
of of really knowing what he's doing
with regard to public health doesn't
matter he's going to be the incoming
health and human services secretary for
no reason
again because the way that biden did
this administration was here are some
people
here are some positions what if i
randomly assign them just pick a card
who wants to be secretary of health and
human services bob
it's you very exciting stuff here was
xavier becerra
openly playing down the response of the
biden administration you see when bad
things happen and you say they're going
to happen
i feel like the joker here but this is
this is how the media approach this
stuff if you say
bad things are going to happen and then
they happen the media take it in stride
if you say bad things are not going to
happen and then they happen this means
that you're a bad person
so here's xavier becerra being like yeah
lots of people are going to die yeah on
on your watch presumably but you won't
get held to account because that's not
the way the media work
i believe president biden is making very
clear
the the the plane is in a nosedive and
we got to pull it up
and you're not going to do that
overnight but we're going to pull it up
we have to pull it up we
can do better we can not only control
covet but get us back to real normality
but it takes everybody all hands on deck
we've got to make sure we're
coordinating
and we are talking to people we can't
just tell the states
here's some ppe some masks here's some
vaccines now go do it no no
okay um what that sounds like a plan
we're going to talk to people
because phones phones are your plan well
done
and then because yeah specifically uh so
one of the vaccines is going to be
available right
your captain plan over here you're
saying you're going to federally
coordinate this whole thing so
when can anyone who wants a vaccine get
a vaccine and sarah's like well
insane and bash like oh sounds great
here's becerra can you give a timeline
well i i i first have to be sworn in
to give you a timeline but what i could
tell you is this uh president biden has
made it
very clear to us we give people straight
shot uh information we don't we don't
try to hide the ball
and once we have that information i
guarantee you we will share it
can you give me a general timeline is
your goal this summer
well let's put it this way the president
before he had an opportunity to be
in the in the oval office when what for
one day had already committed
a hundred million vaccine shots in a
hundred days
okay i'm just going to point out here
that fauci has already backtracked
on this so originally fauci said by a
hundred million vaccine shots
in a hundred days that's what he said he
had 100 million vaccinated
in a hundred million days so 200 million
vaccine shots right because it takes two
shots
okay then fouch was like nope just met
100 million vaccine shots
oh so it sounds like things are going
great over there normalcy
can you feel it can you feel the
normalcy in the air speaking of normalcy
california it turns out they're now
lifting their stay-at-home order on all
regions of california
why that's amazing just as joe biden
took place california
is releasing everybody from their
lockdown and going back to the tier
system
why it's almost as though that's
somewhat political california was asked
for his metrics
and they were like no we're not going to
release that to you you shouldn't know
that
according to ktvu his administration
won't disclose key information that will
help determine when his latest
stay-at-home order is lifted
he's just but today he's announcing that
you're free to you're free to move
around oh that's
that's exciting how incredible by the
way california getting walloped right
now by coven
so obviously everything is working fine
and there's nothing to see here because
everything is boring
and normal guys boring and normal
and gnaring and normal and boring and
boring normal
boringness pretty pretty exciting stuff
okay meanwhile
this week is supposed to launch the
impeachment effort against president
trump in the senate now if you're asking
yourself like
isn't he out of office yes he is indeed
out of office
this goal would be to to prevent him
from ever running for office
again according to the washington post
democratic members of congress are
pressing ahead with preparations for the
second impeachment trial of former
president trump
saying there is a compelling case for
trump to be convicted of inciting an
insurrection and arguing that moving
forward with the trial is imperative
for the country's healing meanwhile
fractures within the republican party
were evident on sunday
gop senators appeared split on whether
it was even constitutional to hold an
impeachment trial for a president who
had already left office
mitt romney said that um they should
push forward an impeachment trial
um because uh we need unity so here is
mitt romney who again voted for the
impeachment the first time around
so he's saying shockingly that he's
gonna vote for impeachment the second
time around and also this will bring
unity right like the first impeachment
trial did
so much unity you can feel the unity it
seems like unity basically is just do
whatever the media
want these days but here is a senator
again i'm not saying senator romney is a
bad moral character for for pushing for
this i think
senator romney is a very moral dude i do
i think he's wrong about this but here's
senator romney
well we're certainly going to have a
trial i i i wish that weren't necessary
but the
the president's conduct with regards to
the call the secretary of state rather
burger in georgia
as well as the incitation towards the
insurrection
uh that led to the attack on the capital
uh calls for a trial
and uh you know if we're going to have
uh unity in our country i think it's
important to recognize the need for
accountability
uh for truth and justice so i think
there will be a trial
and i hope it goes as quickly as
possible but that's up to the council
on both sides okay elizabeth warren said
i can't imagine how republican
opposition to insurrection would fade
over the space of a couple of weeks
it's not that republican opposition to
the attempted insurrection inside the
capitol building faded it's that trump
isn't in office anymore
okay the urgency of making him go away
has somehow faded when he is not the
president of the united states anymore
that happens to be the case okay later
on
on the same show romney was on with
chris wallace rubio said this is stupid
and bad for america
uh and um mike rounds of south dakota
said the same thing he said impeaching
trump is basically a moot point the man
isn't in office anymore
to begin with i think it's a moot point
because i think right now donald trump
is
no longer the president he is a former
president
constitution and i think and i know that
there are other people out there that
may disagree with me but
article one uh sections i think it's
three or
six and seven specifically point out
that you can
impeach the president and it does not
indicate that you can impr
impeach someone who is not in office so
i i think it's a
a moot point and i think it's one that
uh that were that they would have a very
difficult time
in in trying to get done within the
senate uh senator rand paul feels the
same way he said that this is a sham
uh he he writes a piece in the hill
talking about this
he said the first impeachment of donald
trump in 2019 was a witch hunt filled
with fabricated charges unsupported
evidence partisan rancor
disguised as legal concern i worked
against that impeachment i'll grant him
one thing
while wrong headed the democrats had
every right to do it fast forward to
january 2021 a national tragedy occurred
when militants agitators and zealots
were convinced and allowed to believe
that january 6 could produce any results
other than the certification of the
electors of president joe biden
i stood firmly on the side of those who
believe congress should not overturn
state-certified electors and that doing
so might destroy the electoral college
did trump push congress to overturn the
electors yes
did some of my colleagues perform a
little play for their supporters in
which they claimed to be fighting for a
different outcome they all knew couldn't
happen
yes did the combination of an
out-of-control crowd and absolutely
atrocious decisions by those in charge
of our security lead to an unfortunate
event on january 6th also yes
but to argue that any politician that
tells a crowd to fight back to take back
your country
is somehow guilty of incitement is
absurd and this is the the right point
okay this is
forget about the constitutional question
of whether you can impeach a a person
who's no longer sitting in office that's
sort of an open constitutional question
the historical precedent seems to be
that you can impeach somebody
who has or at least convict somebody
after they've already left office in
order to prevent them from running for
office again now i will say
that the political acumen of people like
mitt romney
for saying that they think that if they
push forward here and the republicans
vote to acquit which will probably
happen
right again you need two-thirds of the
senate to vote in favor of a conviction
here which is likely not gonna happen
you'd require 17 republicans
to vote in favor of impeaching trump
here okay if that doesn't happen
and your goal as mitt romney is to or
mitch mcconnell is to minimize trump's
presence in the party going forward
him not being convicted in the senate
would be like the best thing for him
because what trump would then argue
is the reason that they were coming
after me is not because they wanted me
out of office i was already out of
office the reason they came after me is
they wanted
to prevent you from voting for me again
and so i am running again to give you
the opportunity to vote for me again
counterintuitively the the thing that if
republicans
are like done with this and i mean
elected republicans if elected
republicans
politically speaking are saying we're
done with this then pretty much the
worst thing they can do
is push forward with this entire thing
knowing that it's going to fail
because that tends to and as i've said
before i think the american people are
done
with even thinking about this as a
general rule
the the american enthusiasm for
impeachment is very high at the
beginning and then it steadily drops off
post-election impeachment talk in the
middle of a coveted pandemic
in the middle of an economic crisis i
think many americans are being like why
are we talking about trump still
like isn't he not the president didn't
he lose by seven million votes and by
80 electoral votes isn't that is that
what happened on january
6th in any case rand paul makes the
the best sort of principled point with
regard to impeachment he says if we're
to blame politicians for the most
violent acts of their craziest
supporters
many of my colleagues would face some
pretty harsh charges themselves i've
been shot at assaulted and harassed by
supporters of the left including some
who directly said the words of
politicians move them to violence i was
at the ball field when a deranged bernie
sanders supporter almost killed steve
scalise
and seriously wounded several others at
the time democrats were arguing the
geoplan
gop plan for healthcare was you get sick
and then they let you die
is it any wonder and insane left when
gunmen took that rhetoric to heart and
concluded
if the gop is going to let me die maybe
i'll just kill them first interestingly
not one republican stepped up to blame
bernie sanders or suggest he'd be
impeached or held responsible for the
attempted assassination
of more than 20 congressmen and he says
what if this exercise the house started
and the senate is about to take up
which some will dutifully report as
impeachment impeachment is a tool to
remove somebody from office
and again i think the constitutional
question is a lot more unsettled than
paul is making it out to be but
i think that his argument there which is
if the charge is incitement you actually
have to prove incitement
okay and it's very difficult to prove
incitement in a speech in which trump
said i want you to peacefully protest
down at the capitol building
that's a very difficult charge to prove
just on the face of it everybody knows
that if trump were in court there is no
way to prove criminal incitement against
him
on that basis with the rathansburger
call to prove that he was intimidating
raffensburger number one you'd have to
show that he actually had leverage over
a raffensburger and number two you'd
have to show he wasn't just mouthing off
we talked about that
on the show even when it happened many
things can be true at once trump's
behavior could be egregious
and bad and wrong and lying and
anti-factual all that can be true and
also
it can be not a crime and not
particularly impeachable
on the basis of any sort of consistent
principle and that's the question
because
what we're talking about is the
establishment of the consistent
principle anything's impeachable
right it's a political thing you can
impeach anybody for anything
but the but the basic idea of
impeachment for the democrats is of
course political they want to keep trump
top of the headlines the more they keep
trump
this ties back into the idea that what
they are looking for is to contrast
biden's supposed personal normalcy with
donald trump's supposed personal
abnormality
and that way you'll ignore all of the
underlying policy that's shifting
radically in the direction
of a hardcore left and this is why chuck
schumer and the democrats are really
pushing this thing here is chuck schumer
late in the week um explaining bizarrely
that uh president trump actually incited
an erection
i don't know what chuck schumer is
thinking about here that's a weird thing
to say but here we go
make no mistake there will be a trial
and when that trial ends
senators will have to decide if they
believe
donald john donald john trump incited
the erection
insurrection against the united states
okay there we go
by the way anderson cooper apparently
made the same mistake like about about a
week ago so i'm not sure
it's it's a fraught time it's fraught
time in american politics
and meanwhile the the generalized push
in the culture continues to be and this
is going to be i think part of the
pushback
on the right to any sort of impeachment
effort is going to be there is a broader
effort
right now in the media to not just go
after trump obviously but to suggest
that if you don't want trump impeached
or if you ever voted for trump and you
do want him impeached but if you ever
supported any elements of trump you're
part of the abnormality
right the goal of again if the whole
campaign here is we are the new normal
ones
the democrats we're the normal ones
right and look at trump that guy wasn't
normal
we're normal sure we're pushing for a
bunch of random crap that
most americans don't actually like very
much and sure the election was mostly
a referendum on trump's personality
we're gonna make it about policy though
you can see the attempt to lump
everybody who has a generalized
conservative worldview in
with trump that i've said this since the
day that this happened
that there were two actual horrific
events on january 6th
one was the horrific event itself right
and everything surrounding it the
behavior leading up to it the behavior
by trump the behavior by senators
right there's a lot of bad stuff
involved on january 6th acts of evil by
the people who actually perpetrated the
crime at the capitol
okay that was one bad thing that
happened and then
there was the backlash that has now been
caused against 74 million americans on
the other side and it's more than that
because many more people
actually agree with basic conservative
principles than actually voted for trump
the press are going hard after anybody
who disagrees with them
the founding fathers believed that the
greatest protectors of press freedoms
would be members of the press as it
turns out
the people who are leading the charge in
terms of taking away press freedoms are
members of the press
going after their political opponents
this is why you have a piece by margaret
sullivan the media columnist over at the
washington post
about how to basically take fox news off
the air it's an amazing thing fox news
has never called for the washington post
to be taken
out of circulation right trump hated the
washington post
he ripped on the washington post
regularly i can't remember a single
person at fox news ever saying the
washington post
should be de-platformed i don't think
that's ever happened
and yet here was the washington post
quote uh margaret sullivan over at the
washington post
i happened to be watching fox news on
election night when the network startled
the political world by calling arizona
for joe biden
it was a weird moment without the
fanfare that usually accompanied the
announcement that a state
was being put in one column or another a
few hours later the ap made the same
call
many other organizations including the
washington post took days to reach that
daring conclusion
trump world was enraged losing the
traditionally red state would make it
that much harder to proclaim
the election was so close it must in
fact have been stolen by the democrats
it would disrupt the big lie narrative
by the way the fact that the media have
universally taken to calling this the
big lie as in
like joseph goebbels big lie is pretty
astonishingly
tone deaf there's a difference between
saying the election was stolen which is
a lie
and suggesting the jews are responsible
for all our problems let's genocide them
that was the big lie right
like if we're going to use that kind of
term and capitalize big and lie
kind of ugly anyway margaret sullivan
says
last week two key members of fox news's
decision desk decision desk abruptly
departed the network one was laid off
the other has retired
some insiders are calling it a purge in
recent days fox has taken a sharp turn
toward a more extreme approach as it
confronts a post-trump ratings dip
the result of some of its furthest right
viewers moving to outlets like newsmax
and one american news and some
middle-of-the-roaders apparently finding
cnn or msnbc more to their liking
with profits as the one true religion at
fox something had to change
89 year old rupert murdoch according to
a number of reports has stepped in to
call the shots directly most notably the
network has decided to add an hour of
opinion program
programming to its prime time offerings
okay so what is the solution for
margaret sullivan
the solution for margaret sullivan is to
basically
destroy fox news she says how to get the
fox news monster under control
i do not believe the government should
have any role in regulating what can and
can't be said on the air although i
often hear that proposed
that would be a cure worse than the
disease but let's not count on the hope
that fox controlling murdoch's will will
develop a conscience
no the only answer is to speak the
language the bigwigs and fox will
understand
ratings advertising dollars profit
corporations that advertise on fox news
should walk away
citizens who care about the truth should
demand that they do so in addition to
trying to steer their friends and
relatives
away from the network when you think
about fox's role
in the 400 000 us lives lost to the
pandemic it's fair to call their
coverage
deadly some corporations don't want to
be a part of that if reality based
america wants to communicate clearly
with fox news they'll have to do it
in a language they understand the
language of money so here's margaret
sullivan calling for mass boycotts
against a
competing news network meanwhile
armand rosen has a terrific piece over a
tablet mag pointing out how many
journalists are now mobilizing against
free speech
and it's a bunch a bunch over the
weekend a non-jared hardis
an msnbc talking head a new york
university journalism
professor former new york times writer
he tweeted
should fox news be allowed to exist
brain mashing as a business shouldn't be
legal
he continued i'm not a lawyer but i
don't understand why you're not allowed
to manufacture bucatini that doesn't
have a certain threshold of iron in it
but you can broadcast
brain mashing falsehoods and gold people
toward terrorism
so that's pretty astonishing stuff there
from a journalism
professor at new york university how
about steve call
he's a two-time pulitzer prize-winning
dean of columbia journalism school
in a december appearance on msnbc he
decried the wide latitude
of self-expression on facebook he said
those of us in journalism have come to
terms with the fact that free speech
a principle we hold sacred is being
weaponized against the principles
of journalism that's insane
so free speech is bad because it
undermines journalism richard stengel
who is now going to be serving inside
the biden administration he made an
argument that we should have hate speech
laws that are deemed constitutional
he said all speech is not equal where
truth cannot drive out lies we must add
new guard rails masha gessen and andrew
morantz over at the new yorker
they've been writing about how we should
basically restrict media
because free speech can't fulfill its
function if people are allowed to
hear dissenting views they said the news
media have traditionally borne the
responsibility for ensuring that the
actual purpose of the first amendment is
fulfilled
yet americans are content to leave this
essential component of democracy
to profit driven corporations with next
to no regulatory oversight
they complained that mark zuckerberg had
given a speech in which he said free
speech was good
okay this is and the list goes on and on
and on the push by big name members over
at the washington post and the new york
times
max boot last week suggesting that we
ought to regulate outlets they don't
like
okay the push for cancellation is
incredibly strong right now incredibly
and it's only going to get stronger
again to restore normalcy all we have to
do is do unbelievably non-normal things
and then normalcy will be restored
that's exciting i will say that there is
um
some joy to be had uh at least some
sudden fred to be had
in the uh in the fun of watching left
cancel itself so we're watching this
happen on a fairly regular basis now
because once
here's the thing once you let the woke
out of the out of the cage they just go
wild
and that is what's been happening on
social media latest to find herself in
the box
is miley cyrus so that's exciting stuff
miley cyrus who identifies as a bisexual
or pansexual right she said she's
pansexual which means she likes pans
um but also she likes both guys and
girls so she did an interview
with sirius xm's barstool radio where
she said girls are way hotter we know
this
she said that she's not interested in
the male genitalia
and she suggested that everyone knows
that breasts
are prettier than um a uh
male genitalia or prettier uh than
testicles
okay and this is why she says that she's
into girls okay
here's what happened out magazine which
is the lgbt magazine the lgbt magazine
tried to cancel her for saying this so
she says
that she is interested in lesbianism
because of her physical attraction to
women
and out is like that's transphobic i
can't
i will admit that's hilarious that's
really funny here's what out magazine
wrote about all of this a person named
may rude
wrote all of this okay here's what
here's what this person wrote i don't
know what the person
gender is because i have no idea and
literally
no idea okay so here's what this person
wrote quote i wish i could say this news
makes me excited and proud to be a woman
and a lesbian
but cyrus's quote is littered with
transphobia this kind of gender
essentialism
was left behind by most of the queer
community years ago
genitals do not equal gender and miley
should know this
as a lesbian miley cyrus should be
having sex with dudes
and find dude genitalia just as
attractive as non-dude genitalia
you understand this a real lesbian would
be having sex with dudes who say they're
ladies
and if not you're a turf a turf is a
a person who is reinforcing the uh the
anti-trans positions of the lesbian
community
in an age where turfs are more vocal
than they they've ever been
comments like these reinforce some very
dangerous ideas about bodies and genders
says
out magazine having a gender preference
or even a genitalia preference in who
you sleep with
is obviously not a problem but to reduce
the genitalia to men's bodies
contributes to dangerous beliefs about
trans women some
women have penises
clappy hands emoji because so many
people like miley
believe that genitals determine gender
trans women and girls are often
considered to be men
in public spaces oh you mean like men
are considered to be men in public
spaces trans women are kicked out of
women's restrooms
locker rooms and school sports not
allowed in women's shelters put in
prison with men
murdered all because they have male
genitalia okay first of all
andy knows done some interesting work on
the actual number of trans
people who are being murdered is
disproportionate who's actually doing
killing
in any case put that aside for a second
the the basic notion that biological men
should not be allowed in ladies
locker rooms seems fairly
unobjectionable but again everybody is
subject to the cancer culture here is
the thing guys
left right center once you let the cat
out of the bag once you start canceling
people for views you don't like
and once you start conflating your own
views with quote-unquote the facts
there is no limit to the kind of
censorship you will pursue
this is what the left is going to do
this is their push
this is this is what they are this is
what and they're not going to stop
this will continue forever but again at
least we can enjoy
a little bit of uh the schrodinger of of
watching people
who have been doing the canceling in the
past doing the being cancelled
one of these lauren wolfe was an editor
over at the new york times by the way i
don't think she should have been
counseled for this i don't think she
should have lost her editorial job i
think the new york times should just own
it
she tweeted out something about how she
had chills she how she had chills when
joe biden
landed in air force one just
a few months ago she tweeted it's
hilarious this refrain of cancel culture
as if it is actually anything
then she was fired apparently over that
tweet about trump and then she's like
you know when people talk about
canceling they forget that i'm a real
person with a real
life and a real job who now has to make
the bills yes we know
we are aware would that you had picked
up on this a little bit sooner
oh how sad alright it will be later
we'll be here later today with one
additional hour of the ben shapiro show
coming up soon the matt wall show airing
at 1 30 pm eastern
matt will be covering an awful story
about a school that is finally opening
up
prompted by multiple child suicides
you'll want to check that out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show